hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I am
jonald Humphrey we're gonna watch the
trailer for a horror movie that John is
the lead in that's right I'm all over
this joint John is the star of this
movie I am you gotta look hard to see my
eye shine but you'll see it it's gonna
be there it's gonna be front and center
if you're looking at where I am it's
called all the creatures were stirring
yeah it's a Christmas horror anthology
mm-hmm holiday season coming up you know
what Christmas season is all about
scares and that's what we're gonna do
who made this John
Rebecca McKendree shouts out to Rebecca
McKendree who was super awesome she was
my up you got with a little confidence
tip all right let's keep you steady
we're gonna build Connor I think I'm
gonna keep you steady just keep your
your body planted and then now deliver
it by Rebecca McKendree who's a good
friend of mine who I used to work for it
Fangoria then at Blum House and now
she's out here doing her own thing
making movies with her hubby Dave and a
good group of people including me and
actually I'm not on her current set
today so we can shoot this yeah but yeah
I don't know it's been a little while
since I've seen any of this haven't seen
a trailer or anything very curious as to
how they're gonna pitch this movie but
you know shameless self-promotion people
got to do it I mean you are to star them
and the star this movie multiple
characters technically in a way I am the
star of this movie in a way in a sense
if that's spoiler no question that but I
don't think it's a spoiler
[Music]
lady judges say Cox's whoa yeah what an
chase Williamson and the next person can
steal someone else's already open gift
[Music]
there you are
[Music]
Wow Wow oh god Wow is that wow that
looks really good dude yeah that's
really cool you were all up in that
trailer I I was all up in it I actually
- truth be told I am actually one of the
ghouls in the Christmas Carol one but
also the thing that they I don't know
how much to say really but that one shot
I'm in is is from a bigger part of the
movie yes yeah you know you greatly fail
to mention what that Constance Wu is in
this room I wanted that to be a surprise
to whom to you Constance world - oh man
that's crazy
yeah dog Becca know the star she had on
her hands and she made this Oh shall I
go year ago right this has been shot
over a well rear long period of time
kind of so at the time I don't know if
crazy rich Asians was a thing or not but
I mean they were that good your watch it
just push pusher in flesh that fame
factor if she's promoting crazy rich
Asians in other countries forced her to
slip it in there man you got to get the
trailer on to the DVD for crazy rigid
yeah that'll equal the China market and
then go blow yeah I like the trailer man
I mean from a guy who doesn't know
anything about any of the specifics of
what's going on in here I think the
production designs of everything looks
really cool like the visuals of the
goals that are playing on the Ebenezer
Scrooge tale but in a real horror
fashion look really exciting this
anthology said yeah like like a creep
show or trick-or-treat kind of movie I
really like that kind of film - this
looks like a lot of fun this is over -
for comedy right and it looks like it's
doing both pretty well and I think
Christmas movie horror films like
everywhere Lee get a good one this looks
like this has a lot of potential to be
something that's very entertaining and
engage
and I just I hope that people watch it
cuz like Christmas horror movies when
their Goods still don't get recognition
and we kind of get a good one every
other year but no one ever really
remembers that I feel like she could be
something you get a lot of like little
think pieces on the horror websites
about like are you looking for a
Christmas movie to watch yeah but yeah
it's a kind of underserved genre and I
get why but yeah I think you know as it
goes with most anthologies if you're not
about one segment you'll probably be
about another and I don't know exactly
where the film has gone since last time
I saw a cut but came out pretty fun I
think you think so I think so you're not
just saying that I'm not just saying was
this moment that you're in that one time
I slightly helped you out before you
went to go film yes actually you you
helped me out a great deal and yeah well
my [ __ ] recognition I mean you you
helped me getting a good mindset in the
feedback I got from the people around
was pretty good yeah all Greg no no work
from John that part yeah Greg do any of
the labor basically what I did prepare
for that role was every time I stepped
onto the little black box theater stage
here for this segment I closed my eyes
and thought of you
and then imagine myself entering your
brain and coming you should and I play
the character is you this is basically
you know if you want to see me
channeling Greg that's basically what
this was I appreciate you doing that I
appreciate you doing it yeah yeah every
one of my credits comes with a sub
credit that says and my acting coach
Greg Allen you know because you really
played that role through me I didn't
really do much I appreciate you saying
that because I was gonna try to audition
myself on camera maybe I should do a
profile shot just so you know when my
hair falls down like this it looks a
little different every time like right
now it's doing this weird like kind of
balding spot over here but then some
days he doesn't look like that at all
you know but that's where your
special-effects makeup design like this
is so strange to see one of these blocks
where you're like
I know all those yeah it's got a good
cast and stuff yeah dear faces you'll
recognize peeps a lot of people who be
blown up lately - wait did you meet
Constance I was not on set for that
segment you son of a [ __ ] I got to
haunt John kite for a while from -
broker Oh John kite not crazy rich
Asians house key your former buddy Ian
Gutowski is falling out well I haven't
seen him in a long time or heard his
name in a long time but he was coaching
him for stand-up during that moment in
time oh good this should be on Netflix I
feel like yeah it would be nice I know
they have a VOD you know distribution
deal right now well it should be on
Netflix so he lost in the can
[Laughter]
Oh watch today although I gotta say if
Netflix had some kind of category for
Christmas horror I can't imagine that
scroll would last very long so you
actually might be able to make a choice
yeah this actually looks really cool
I'll make sure to check in it and I met
one of the producers - at the Mandy
premiere right yeah you met JP you let
know that was that
oh no you meant joke I met JP at his
Shakespeare the Shakespeare movie and
then you met Joe wicker at Mandy the man
yes
yeah yeah and I had lunch with Becca at
that one place and then I rode in the
car with David yeah I do
on the way to watch oh yeah no we don't
watch alien coming in at the Fox and I
touched myself to constants that's why
we can't go back to how we can't go back
to AMC Burbank really got it you really
gave us a Fred Willard Thanks do not
touch my something with no
considerations but we all respect this I
just don't touch myself to celebrities
because I just don't touch myself just
just for safekeeping I don't all right
guys we'll all the creatures were
stirring yeah that's a cool title man
right you're doing something right guys
well done your fallback plan should be
making
will be available December Ford yeah
John's definitely gonna get a copy
mm-hmm in the mail and and on VOD and on
demand she goes to support he goes all
out to buy every ticket I number-one
customer that's right man and you guys
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to get notified
every time a video is up check us out on
patreon where we do TV show reactions q
and A's and John does music video
coverage as well I sometimes pop in to
be like Eminem Eminem doing a song sure
one kind of music video I like out